[Applause]
[Music]
Ethiopia is a country famous for being
the home of the coffee plants however
Ethiopians themselves didn't start
drinking it until very recently the
countless decades this country was among
the world's poorest but if you followed
visual politic for a while you already
know that Ethiopia was blessed with one
of the greatest miracles of the time
[Music]
in recent decades Ethiopia is grown at a
rate of 10% year after year in this
country fashion brands like Calvin Klein
and H&M have opened large textile
workshops and Chinese factories are
being built along the outskirts of Addis
Ababa at a startling pace but the
Chinese are not the only ones interested
in making money in Ethiopia at the
beginning of 2019 high-end eye opens
their first assembly plants here in
other words more and more Ethiopians are
stepping out of poverty every day but
hold on for just a second because this
isn't actually the Ethiopian miracle you
see until the year 2018 the economy was
doing well but the political system it
kind of sucked they had an authoritarian
system just like that of the Chinese
Communist Party one party that was
censorship and was never-ending
harassment and abuse of ethnic
minorities but one day against all odds
something shocking happens and a lot
changed thanks to the man that you see
on screen right now
this man is Adi ahmed ali the brand's
new Ethiopian Prime Minister and I say
against all odds because ABI Achmed Ali
was the last person you would imagine to
be a reformist he was an Army General
and a member of the establishment party
the Ethiopian People's Liberation Front
stream
however as soon as this man took a step
into office as Prime Minister he started
rocking the boat
from one day to the next he abolished
most of the censorship laws bans the
harassment of minority groups by the
army and announced free elections by
2020 and to this the peace with
neighboring Eritrea he negotiated and
the liberalisation agenda that sounds
like heaven to international investors
and well yes it might be the case that
he gets the chance to receive a Nobel
Peace Prize he definitely already
deserves it much more than many others
who've received it but hold on a minute
because believe it or not in Ethiopia
not everything is sunshine and rainbows
YES on paper the intentions of this
politician couldn't sound better if he
achieves everything he wants he would
become an easy-open national hero for
generations to come and a symbol of
democracy in Africa but as we always say
here on visual politics things are a bit
more complicated than they seem
[Music]
Ethiopia's Amhara state chief killed
amid regional coup attempt yep you heard
that right democratic transitions are
never easy especially considering that
Ethiopia already has a political elite
enjoying the privileges of the
establishments and more than 13
different distinct and divided
ethnicities we are talking about an
enormous country of more than a hundred
million people speaking more than 13
languages this is a test - Adi Ahmed
real intentions with so much opposition
and so much ethnic tension and conflict
it's very tempting to go back to the
good old days of dictatorship at the end
of the day tyrants can deal with such
disorder much more easily so to what
extent is avi Achmed really willing to
respect human rights Kerry Theo Pia
become an actual democracy or maybe it's
too hard to just resist the temptation
of becoming an authoritarian
dictatorship again well today we are
going to answer all of these questions
but before we do let's take a look back
at the history
[Music]
the country of three revolutions many of
you might associate Ethiopia with
Rastafarians as you know Bob Marley and
his acolytes practiced a religion that
revered Haile Selassie the Ethiopian
Emperor not to offend the Rastafarians
but Emperor Selassie was an absolute
monarch that ruled Ethiopia with an iron
fist and as it tends to be with
absolutist leaders he didn't die in met
in the year 1975 a guerrilla
organization known as the Derg seized
power and slew him at the ripe old age
of 83 after 35 years of rule this was
the first Ethiopian Revolution
revolutions rarely go as well as plans
though but even more rarely do they go
as horrible as they did in Ethiopia the
Derg was a Marxist Leninist group that
governs the country during the 1980s in
this time they collectivized lands
nationalized all the companies and began
what would become known as the gays
shibir or the Ethiopian red terror which
resulted in half a million dead
political dissidents horrible policies
mixed with low rainfall resulted in one
of the worst famines in Ethiopian
history
[Music]
subsequently another uprising occurred
in 1991 after a bloody civil war the
Ethiopian People's Liberation Front took
power this was the second Ethiopian
Revolution
unfortunately this revolution it wasn't
very liberal either they went from a
pure communism to a Mulder one with
Chinese characteristics and it's the
good relationship between these two
countries and the country's economic
growth but pay attention because now
Eric is going to tell us the really
interesting part of the story
you see Ethiopia has more than 100
million citizens and over 13 tribes
these tribes are not always very
friendly with one another and that's why
the Constitution is so special
start with Ethiopia is the only country
on earth besides Liechtenstein where the
right to secession is part of the
Constitution this means that
theoretically each of these nine regions
you see on the map could have a
referendum and become independent each
of these ethnicities has their own
political party
most of these political parties are part
of this grand coalition called the
Ethiopian People's Liberation of France
all these parties have seats in the
parliaments all of this means that
Ethiopian politics are not a debate
between right and left wing or
conservative versus liberal instead it's
a debate amongst squabbling tribes and
you might wonder does the system work
can Ethiopians but assign their
differences and coexist in peace and
harmony and the answer well no first of
all this right to secession is just a
theory
each time a region wanted to secede they
had to face the army and as you can
imagine not all tribes are equal
from those 13 ethnic groups only 3 call
the shot the Oromo the 'm hara and the
Tyrians
the rest are suffering constant human
rights violations these include but are
not limited to force displacements land
confiscations and of course the
occasional slaughter for example these
Somalians living in ethiopia have been
suffering neverending abuses by
paramilitary groups and of course both
the government and the military deny
such things if that wasn't enough easy
opa was in a seemingly endless war with
Eritrea a region that succeeded in
secession only through force
so yes the economy was doing well but
the political situation it could hardly
be worse this all set the stage for the
third Ethiopian revolution so let's have
a look at that shall we
[Music]
the Ethiopian rock star I'm gonna say it
again
remember this name because he might one
day win a Nobel Peace Prize
howdy Ahmed Ali until 2018 he was what
we call an apparatchik this is a party
man an army general that belonged to an
Oromo tribe as he said before these are
one of the ruling ethnic groups
nevertheless as soon as he started his
administration he unleashed one of the
most ambitious reformist agendas in
history in one year he signed a peace
treaty with Eritrea abolished censorship
and has blocked abuses by the military
Ahn's impressed yes well just wait
because we haven't finished he has
already announced free elections managed
to get a woman as president since is
passing the biggest liberalisation ever
seen in Ethiopia
Ethiopia to install 4G network ahead of
telecoms liberalisation with all of this
is easy to understand why is the come
the new African rock star in fact we can
already talk about Abbey mania and
believe me everything I say here is not
hyperbole at all some religious groups
already claim that he is the Messiah
feats that he shares with the late Haile
Selassie in Eritrea the former diehard
enemy of Ethiopia there are already
mothers naming their children after him
not to mention the Ethiopian media is
having a big time Renaissance satire is
flourishing in Ethiopia brand-new
newspapers brand-new TV shows an exiled
journalists coming back to the country
the pictures you see now a part of a
comedy sketch that you can find on
YouTube for the first time in Ethiopian
history people could make fun of
politicians including the Prime Minister
and it seems that next year Ethiopian
broadcaster will start a late-night show
similar to the Daily Show
all of this is pretty normal in a
country like America or the UK but it is
a giant step here
but okay okay I know what you're gonna
say now it's easy to allow free press
when the media loves you but what
happens when you have diehard critics
well let's cover that now freedom has
its risks 2019 surprised Ethiopians with
a terrible drought that brought many
regions to the brink of starvation
unemployment is near 20 percent and many
young people are in a desperate
situation if that wasn't enough the old
guard is far from happy with this third
revolution see what happens in June 2019
is the open army chief killed by
bodyguard and regional leader dead in
coup attempt the um Hara state president
mbaku Makonnen and his advisor were shot
dead and the state's attorney general
was wounded in Amar's capital basically
a man from the military who belongs to
the Amara tribe decided to kill the
governor of his region according to him
maybe Achmed was ending all the
privileges that his tribe used to enjoy
so he organized a coup d'etat to
separate from the rest of the country as
you can imagine the central government
did not wait to retaliate Ethiopia
security forces kill alleged coup leader
but we're not talking about a military
answer only for almost two days the
central government cut access to the
internet and just like that for the next
48 hours Ethiopians nationwide didn't
have any internet access this way the
citizenry couldn't visit any media or
any site with a critical opinion of the
government so yeah I can probably tell
you're thinking freedom of speech didn't
last long at all but if you thought this
was the only problem that he has one you
better think again
Ethiopia referendum dozens killed in
Sudama clashes with so much freedom the
Sudama tribe one of those groups that
have always been marginalized by the
powers that be decided to call for an
independence referendum they don't want
to become an independent country but
rather they wanted to have their own
autonomous region within Ethiopia like
some larger ethnic groups have this is
what happens when you give freedom to
the people people want to use that
freedom and at this moment the guys from
the Ethiopian government said
essentially well these guys are a
massive pain in the ass okay so you
sudharma guys do what you want you want
to referendum fine but can you wait five
months just just hold on five months and
then the Sudama tribe said oh yeah just
five months your wages five months I
mean you just sound like the previous
government guys you talk about democracy
you talk about freedom all that sweet
stuff but then you go around with
referendums you can take your five
months waiting time and you can stick it
up your ops and that is how violent
protests ending with over 30 deaths
happen certainly guess what you're
thinking this abbey ahmed guy that's
pretty disappointing but well sometimes
history can be really beautiful
[Music]
Ethiopia to hold autonomy referendum for
ethnic Sudama in November yes after much
hesitation avi Achmed is really willing
to allow that referendum coupled with
the internet already working again it
seems that freedom of speech is alive in
Ethiopia for example while we were
preparing this video we found some
English speaking Ethiopian newspapers
and we could find news pieces like this
one Sudama unrest toll rises to 34 I
know this is really bad news this is the
kind of news that doesn't paint a nice
portion of the government but that's
precisely it the fact that an Ethiopian
newspaper can now say bad things about
the government is an amazing thing good
luck finding something similar in China
for a better understanding do HVL which
is a radio program similar to the BBC
but in germany has already started
broadcasting in Amharic language and
look at the kind of talk shows that they
already are hosting discussion country
risk they began to hear warnings that
Ethiopia was endangered as a country
unfortunately we don't really know what
they are discussing in this talk show
because we couldn't find an Ethiopian
who could help us so far Abby is giving
us promise of free elections by 2020 of
course this will not be an easy thing
first of all Ethiopia will have to
perform a new census which is extremely
hard to do rather despite the growth
this is still a very poor country and
the government has a lot of challenges
ahead of it starting with the huge
unemployment rate so the question goes
to you should Ethiopia be able to hold
these elections by 2020 will a bee fall
to the temptations of the fruits of
authoritarianism
also is Ethiopia ready for democracy
well please leave your answer in the
comment section below also do visit our
friends from reconsider mediacom they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also don't forget we
publish brand new videos every week so
subscribe to visual politic hit that
Bell button so you won't miss a post if
you like this video give it a thumbs up
and I'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more about politics and
here even more of my lovely voice you
can join us at reconsider media we have
a podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]